[موسيقى]
والله هون مخيمات ساكنين وما بي شغل غير
هالسنه صناعات ما ابي ما ابي الا شغل
الحراسات بس مجبور
عند اخويان سرطان الى خمس سنين انها
الحراقات
ه تراكس عنا واستشهد ابو محمود
[موسيقى]
انا اسمي محمود الحميد عمري 16 سنه بشتغل
بهالحراقات مشان اعين اهلي الرقاط نفض
نجيب
ونحط بيه
ومنشغله والله انا بشتغل بالطبخ
اشتغل 24 ساعه عم بنشغل طبخه
[موسيقى]
هذا الفيول الخام منجيبه
ونعبيه بالحراقه
بالتراكتور
ونشغل عليه
الحراقه الطبخه
ب 60 ساعه والستين ساعه هي بدنا نراقبها
على السوائل ما رقبناها يعني قابل تنفجر
اي ساعه ما بتعرف لانه هاي قنبله مخفيه
علينا
[موسيقى]
بعد تقريبا 3 تفرز شو اسمه
كويس
[موسيقى]
300 برميل
تصير طالع حمراء بعدين بعد الحمراء بتطالع
قوي بعد العريق
ونروح مرات مرات بنروح على بيوتنا بتبريد
وعلينا التبريد نبرد ونبيع
[موسيقى]
ك ابوي
دارنا ضرب البراميل انهدمت وطلعنا من من
ضيعه وصلنا هون وقاعدنا بقى بهالمخيم هذا
ونضطر على الولد نبعته على الحراقات وخطر
الحراقه
وبنخاف عليه الدنيا بس ايش ما طالع بيدنا
شيء
عيله كبيره بدي وماشي
وهالغلاء وهالشي
مصروف
من قلبنا
من خوفنا عليه
مدلل صغيره
كان صغير العيله وهذا هو صغير ما بطلع
بالايد شي كبار العناني على الحراقه هذا
مريض السلطه وهذاك مريض الدوسيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كنت اشتغل ممرض وادرس
صارت هالحرب وبيع عيال وبده مصروف عفت
الدراسه وقفت
دورت حرقنا بغير الحراقات وما تريد تريد
صار عندي اوجاع وهيك من هالحراقه
كل واحد على الدكاتره وصار عندي ورم
برغبتي
وبجسمي
عملوا لي عمليه قالوا لي معك سرطان صار لي
بيجي خمس سنين علاج اربع سنين بتركيا وقبل
هون تعالجت اخذت حسابي جراح
والحراقات بتسبب انه هالامراض هالغاز انه
بسيط ضيق التنفس الحين
لقدام واحد
يصير معه المرض وانا وعد الناس صار معاي
[موسيقى]
بدات هذه
المنشات الصغيره او الفرديه بالظهور هنا
لتلبيه احتياج المنطقه من كان في البدايه
لمواد التدفئه ثم تطور الوقود السيارات
وقود المعامل
بشكلها
البدايه سابقا وتم تطويرها ولكن التطوير
محدود يقتصر على سعه الخزانات التكرير
وموضوع المساحات المستخدمه في في كل مصفاه
او منشاه لا على جوده ومواضيع اخرى
والحاجه هنا ملحه بسبب الكثافه السكانيه
الموجوده في المنطقه المنطقه هنا
خاليه من اي تواجد لحقول النفط ومنابع
النفط
جميعها موجوده في مناطق سيطره قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وعدم وجود حدود مسموح العبور
منها بشكل يعني انسيابي ووجود مصافي
التكرير ايضا الخاصه بالنفط بالنسبه
للداخل السوري
في مناطق بانياس وطرطوس وحمص هنا يباع
لاهل المنطقه من جرابلس الى ادلب هاي
المنطقه كلها تقريبا تغطى من هنا وسبب ذلك
قله اسعار مشتقات النفطيه التي تخرج من
هذا التكرير البدائي عن اسعار المشتقات
النفطيه التي تاتي مستورده
[موسيقى]
حسيت الذنب لازم ما اشتغل هيك شغل
وبصير معنا ضيقه نفس كتير
صدرنا كتير بوجعنا من الغاز غاز يعني
الراقات والاخير يعني على عمر كبير لا
يصيبك سرطان
لجسمك بتعب
[موسيقى]
العيون
مشان هيك بناخذ ابر ليمشي حالنا
شي نهارين
طلعنا الضوء ولا الشمس
عيوننا
تصير توجعنا تحرقنا
نجيب اللون قطران
[موسيقى]
حقيقه من خلال عملي منطقه الحراقات شفنا
عده اضطرابات مرضيه ومشاكل صحيه خاصه بتلك
المنطقه نتيجه استخدام الفيول التاثير
الاني والسريع على الجهاز التنفسي هو
التهاب القصيبات الشعريه او التهاب
القصبات بكل اشكاله نتيجه هذه المواد
اغلبها مواد مخرجه يعني نحسن نعتبره
التهاب مبدئيا كيميائي قد يتلف النسيج
الرئوي طبعا هذه الالتهابات المتكرره قد
تسبب التليفوي والحاله الثانيه حاله
التغبر الرئوي طبعا على التليف الرئوي
والتقبل الرئوي كلها مؤهلات لاصابه بمرض
اخطر
ولا وهو سرطان الرئه ارتفعت نسبته ولكن لا
ليس هناك دراسات عن هذا الموضوع ابدا
[موسيقى]
استعجبنا لحالات حرائق كثيره ضمن حركات
ترحين وصار فيها استجمنا كمان لحالات
اسعاف منهم حالات اغماء حالات اختلاجات
حالات كمان حروق للعمال اللي عم بشتغلوا
ضمن الحراقات حالات ضيق تنفس بشكل عام
للاسف انه اغلب العمال ضمن الحراقات هم
يعني يعتبرون اطفال تحت اقل من 18 سنه هو
موقف مؤثر لاني اغلب الحالات اللي عملها
هي بشكل عام ضمن الح
[موسيقى]
الحرايه هي كلها عباره عن احتراق ماده
الفيول ضمن الحراقه اما عن طريق مثلا
الثقب ضمن الحراقه او اشتعال خط الغاز او
انفجار الحراقه بشكل كامل وانتشار النيران
حجم الحراره في شكل كبير كبير جدا
وعوره الطرقات هذا الشكل شكل سلبي باثر
بشكل سلبي لوصول لمكان الحريق بشكل اسرع
واخماد الحريق بلحظاته الاولى وعدم
انتشاره الى المجاور على هذا الشيء اكيد
بشكل صعوبه وبسبب سوء كمان ماده الفيول
اللي عم بتاثر بشكل حراري كبيره ضمن
المنطقه احنا رحنا شهيد ضمن المركز
الترحيل بسبب انفجار احد الخزانات الوقود
واحتار تراكس عنا واستشهد
ابو محمود
[موسيقى]
الله
خلاص
[موسيقى]
اتمنى اصير مثله عم بطلع الصبح على الشغل
فبتمنى
[موسيقى]
الغاز
انا كنت فاتح له الباب المصب ما حصل اشرق
غاز ما وصلت شي خمسه امتار القاعده بعدين
ما حسيت بشيء
واخوي كمان
ظاهره معروفه محليا باسم ظاهره التعليس
وحقيقه هي تسمم بقاس كبريت الهيدروجين
غالبا هو تسمم الهيدروجين الذي يسبب شلل
في الاغراض التنفسيه انا خلال عملي في تلك
العياده مرت علي حالتان وكان المريض
المريضين متوفيين
[موسيقى]
وكتابه ما بعرف انه بحياتي
جربت بس امكانيه اخوتي كل شهرين يا الله
يا الله انشغل طبخه
ستين دولار
علينا دين
[موسيقى]